[KEYBOARD CLICKING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Hey, Jarek.
What's happening?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
I'm coding this--
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Oh, that's great.
Say, listen.
I've been talking to
the folks upstairs.
And we think we need to make
our apps a little more freemium.
Do you think you
can do that for us?
Maybe add a little
freemiumification to our apps?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Do you even
know what freemium means?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Jarek, look.
I'm more of what you
might want to call
a big-picture kind of guy.
I don't like to get
bogged down in details
like what is freemium, and
what does that even mean?
I like to leave that
people like you.
So what do you say?
Can you get this done for me?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Well, we could
reshuffle the schedule and--
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's great.
Hey, listen.
I kind of told the folks
in upper management
we'd have something
for them on Monday.
So I'm going to have to ask
you to come in over the weekend
to get this done for me, OK?
Thanks a lot, Jarek.
You're a team player.
MALE SPEAKER 2: It's "Yarek."
MALE SPEAKER 1: Keep
up the good work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]